there's nothing to worry about that's
the message from the head of the un's
nuclear Watchdog for those concerned
about the release of treated radioactive
water from Japan's Fukushima nuclear
plant our conclusion has been that this
plan if it if it is carried out in the
way it has been presented will be in
line would be in Conformity with the
international
safety standards and we understand
that preoccupations and concerns remain
Raphael Grossi is touring East Asia
seeking to ease tension over the plan
but critics among South Korea's
opposition appear unconvinced
if Miss Degrassi is sure the water's
safe enough is he willing to advise the
government of Japan a water deprived
country to use it as drinking water or
industrial or agricultural water instead
of discharging it into the sea
Bruce's visit to South Korea brought
hundreds of protesters onto the streets
the international atomic energy agency
says the water will have a negligible
effect on the environment
South Korean government agrees but some
among the public remain skeptical
they say there are only a few risks
possible but what if that really happens
and who's going to be responsible for
that the government is saying the iaea
report is accurate but the report says
they are not taking any responsibility
what kind of report is that this is
worse than kids school homework after a
15 meter tsunami disabled three nuclear
reactors at the Fukushima plant in 2011
water was used to cool the cores of
three of them
ground and rainwater also seeped in the
water was treated and began to be stored
in more than a thousand tanks at the
site more than a decade later they're
now nearly full 1.3 million tons of
Wastewater enough to fill 500 Olympic
swimming pools
Japanese officials say it needs to be
removed but the plan to be fully
decommissioned
the planet sparked criticism in South
Korea China and North Korea as well as
Japan itself
no date has been set for the water to be
released but now that Japan has the
approval of the iaea it's expected to
happen soon Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera